winter is coming but could it pick up
the pace a little bit
Game of Thrones is back season 7 episode
1 Dragonstone has aired odd this is not
going to be spoiler free I'm going to
get into spoilers pretty much right off
the bat which you kind of have to if
you're going to touch Game of Thrones I
learned that the hard way so if you're
looking for a general overview you're
not really going to get it before I
start getting into spoilers so just
watch the show and come back so will
okay um I guess my thing is there's
nothing wrong with this uh well there's
something I think is wrong there's
nothing bad in it no one part no one
character no one thing that is shown was
something that was bad something that I
don't like but aside from the opening
scene with Arya and Walder Frey and all
that it was dull it was all set up and I
get that all the stuff that they were
doing was stuff that needed to be
addressed in terms of reestablishing
where but where everybody is what's
their goal what's standing in their way
but the show as a whole does this
sometimes they like load all the similar
material into a into a single episode
and we get like the exposition episode
VIII moving the pieces around the
chessboard episode and or you know the
action episode and sometimes when it you
know they're culminating all the high
end stuff together or the world of
really intense stuff it works a bit
better but when they lump together
similar stuff that's all kind of slow
and like I said there's not the first
episode they've ever done it it's kind
of annoying I think it bugs me a little
bit more this time than it would
otherwise because there's only seven
episodes this season so to get an
episode that feels like nothing but
setup kind of bugs me again that said
nothing both it's all fine there's
there's even some stuff that I really
like it opened great especially because
the scene started with Walder Frey you
know and all these people I'm like are
we getting a flash
- the red wedding like from a different
angle and then he's toasting these
people I'm like and for a minute I still
thought it was a flashback like him
toasting and congratulating his people
who had just done the red wedding and
then realizing no there's not a
flashback oh boy I figured he was
poisoning all of them right away but I
still thought we were in a flashback for
a little while until I caught it oh wait
a minute and then she pulls the face off
is like yes yes and I'd like winning
when that gets brought up with searcy
and Jaime talking about it that they
don't know it's her which was a nice
reminder I think I known on some level
in my head that you know kinda nobody
knows Arya is alive or what she's up to
but it was just nice to get a reminder
like concretely that anything she does
they don't know what just happened as
far as they're concerned the phrase just
I'll drop dead and that and that's kind
of cool when I got to put my my head on
do remember not every character knows
what I know so that was kind of a cool
thing to think about the other scene I
think that I liked the most in addition
to that one and there's one other that
was really good and I'll come back to
that but you're on kiss scene in front
of Searcy sold me on his character much
better than his appearances last season
did last season when he showed up I'm
like what's the point of this guy why
are we doing this I gave him much better
the character just placed on this one
scene and it's interaction with Searcy
when Jamie and his reactions to how she
try and seriously place him so smart and
but his reactions all this like I get
this guy's deal now and more to the
point he's fun I always like fun fun
characters are great so the other scene
that I mentioned that I do really
particularly like is Sansa and John
talking after the sort of the council
thing where John decides he's got to
pardon these families that hadn't hadn't
betrayed the Starks with Sansa
questioning him right there in front of
everybody and they have this scene that
I think plays really well because it
shows the validity of both sides because
Jon makes him makes a very good case in
terms of the rightness of what he's
doing but Sansa who was at King's
Landing who saw the inner workings of
the politics and who knows how the game
is played whereas John just doesn't I
mean John was John was up at the wall
where backstabbing was very upfront
because it was literal he's not used to
the weird political infighting sort of
thing and Sansa is and she knows that
and I there was something about that
moment when she said to him look I miss
father I'm miss Rob they were they were
wonderful men but you have to be smarter
because what they did got them killed
and that's just I'm hoping that what
this is building towards is not the two
of them butting heads but the two of
them putting their heads together what I
want to see is John recognizing the
value of what she's saying and and
giving her the opportunity to use all
the horrible substitute through to the
best possible end that that is my hope
for the two of them going forward and I
mean the rest was just a bunch of little
scenes I get all of which in and of
themselves taken completely
independently we're fine or even good
it's just they added up to a very dull
tone for this first episode oh the other
thing that I like I'm not so much like
it was a big thing in this episode but I
like as far as a set up because I had to
think about a dad to realize what a big
deal it was was Sam's realization that
basically all the dragonglass is that
Dragons own I'm like oh well yeah that
makes sense but then you know they
actually show the map it's like oh wait
there's something between John who needs
the dragonglass
and where all the dragon glass is and
there's king planting it's Searcy ah
crap and sort of realizing what a big
problem that's going to be that um you
know that was just sort of a cool thing
to think about and like pretty much
everything was getting set up is all
stuff that I like so I do think this
sets up a potentially very good season
or and
a very good next episode but it's also
the kind of episode that if I were
rewatching the season I would probably
skip not because it's bad just because
it's like a what victim first stop and I
I feel like this is stalling for me and
you know there have been slower more you
know paced episodes like this that I've
enjoyed earlier in the show you know
before it was really hitting the the
culmination of everything and that's
where we are now so these kinds of
slowdowns weigh on me a lot more than
they than they did or would have in
previous seasons although I'm pretty
sure I was pointing out when this kind
of let's lump all the boring stuff into
one episode thing would happen but I
think it's just weighing on me more this
time than it would normally but again
still good it's a it's a solid start in
terms of what it's setting up it just
didn't grab me but it does not make me
worried about the show and it doesn't
make me worried about the season I'm
just hoping that now that all the subs
all the way we can hit the ground
running on the next one so those are my
thoughts on the first episode of the new
season of Game of Thrones have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]